ils ne s'étaient pas revus depuis
plusieurs mois ces enfants âgés entre 7
et 10 ans font tous partie de leurs
quatre demos ce dispositif d'éducation
musicale et orchestrale à vocation
sociale est financé notamment par le
département des yvelines
coordonné par la philharmonie de paris
il existe depuis 2007 à chanteloup les
vignes
l'idée c'est que c'est des enfants qu'on
jamais touché à la musique et qui par ce
biais de ce dispositif
et là ils vont pouvoir continuer
éventuellement en faire parce qu'au bout
des trois ans si jamais ils ont continué
et ils ont eu de l'appétence pour cette
pratique
l'instrument est offert les enfants
suivent quatre heures de cours par
semaine et des cours qui ont dû être
suspendues en raison du confinement des
parents m'ont dit tout simplement qu'ils
n'étaient pas eux mêmes musiciens
donc c'est vrai que c'est très compliqué
en fait de pouvoir soutenir son enfant
sur un instrument qu'on a parce qu'on
n'a pas forcément fait notamment les
cuivres trompette trombone ou encore le
faut nous y sommes
ce stage d'été permet à ces jeunes
mélomanes de reprendre leurs instruments
en est là c'est 1 2
un récapitulatif de tout ce qu'on a
appris depuis le début de l'année que là
on essaie de remettre à niveau tout ce
qu'on avait appris
[Musique]
des fois je n'arrive pas à faire des
sons le coup c'est difficile pour moi
des fois on se trompe mais on recommence
cesse pas très rares à chanteloup les
vignes les ateliers reprendront en
septembre
au total sept communes participent au
projet demos dans les yvelines